[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serin schönen guten Abend zusammen
der Blick auf die deutschen champions
league teams heute hast du wieder später
Christian fünf dabei guten Abend und wir
blicken jetzt auf die Themen der der
Sendung späte Konsequenz nach der
Flutkatastrophe im Aartal der
Innenminister von Rheinland-Pfalz Roger
lewens räumt Fehler ein und tritt zurück
düstere Aussichten für die Konjunktur
die Herbstprognose der Bundesregierung
sieht die Gefahr einer Rezession
silensky im ZDF-Interview der
ukrainische Präsident bedankt sich bei
Deutschland für die Militärhilfe
[Musik]
jede Menge Unstimmigkeiten und jede
Menge Zeit bis Konsequenzen gezogen
wurden heute 15 Monate nach der
Flutkatastrophe im Ahrtal ist der
rheinland-pfälzische Innenminister
lewenz zurückgetreten als Krisenmanager
geriet er auch deswegen in die Kritik
weil nicht klar wurde wann er genau vom
Ausmaß der Katastrophe wusste neues
Bildmaterial hat dann den Druck
verstärkt erst kürzlich waren Polizei
Videos aufgetaucht der Bericht der
Piloten wurde noch in der flutnacht an
das Innenministerium übermittelt die
Dimension der Naturgewalten war damit
bekannt allein im Ahrtal kamen damals
134 Menschen ums Leben Marion Geiger
berichtet
diese Bilder waren lange verschwunden
Aufnahmen eines Polizeihubschraubers die
zeigen wie verzweifelt die Lage war in
der flutnacht an der Ahr ein
geschlossene Menschen Flehen um Hilfe
Häuser bis zum Dach im reißenden Wasser
mit dem Auftauchen der Bilder geriet der
rheinland-pfälzische Innenminister
massiv unter Druck denn wie sich
herausstellte wurde seinem Lagezentrum
damals mündlich und schriftlich
berichtet und das heißt anders als
bisher behauptet lagen belastbare
Informationen vor über das Ausmaß der
Katastrophe heute übernehme ich für mein
Verantwortungsbereich gemachte Fehler
die politische Verantwortung
ich habe unseren Ministerpräsidentin sie
hat es eben ausgeführt mein Rücktritt
als Staatsminister das Minister des
Innern und für Sport angeboten
ist das erste Mal das seitens der
Landesregierung eigene Fehler in der
katastrophennacht eingeräumt werden die
Landrätin im Aartal sieht im Rücktritt
des Innenministers eine Chance für den
Kreis ist das
unter anderem das Signal und die
Hoffnung dass die Geschehnisse gut
analysiert werden können um daraus zu
lernen vor allem auch für den
Katastrophenschutz auf Landesebene und
auch länderübergreifen zu lernen für die
Opposition in Mainz war der Rücktritt
von Roger lewens überfällig
der Innenminister hat sich vorhin aber
nicht für persönliche Fehler und
Fehleinschätzungen entschuldigt
sein Rücktritt erfolgt nicht aus
persönlicher Einsicht sondern wegen der
erdrückenden Beweislage im
Untersuchungsausschuss
warum wurden trotz dieser Bilder die
Menschen weiterflussabwärts nicht
gewarnt der Untersuchungsausschuss in
Mainz ermittelt weiter die nächste
Sitzung ist übermorgen
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister schwört
Deutschland auf wirtschaftlich härtere
Zeiten ein auch wegen gestoppter
russischer Gaslieferungen rutscht
Deutschland Richtung Rezession aber so
Robert Habeck die Zahlen die hätten auch
noch viel schlimmer ausfallen können wir
blicken erst einmal auf die Inflation
für dieses Jahr erwartet die
Bundesregierung eine Teuerungsrate von
8%. 2023 wird mit 7% gerechnet düster
auch die Wirtschaftsaussichten in diesem
Jahr soll es noch ein Wachstum von 1,4
Prozent geben aber es droht eine
Rezession minus 0,4 Prozent so die
Prognose für 2023 Karl Hinterleitner hat
mehr
russland hat den Gashand zugedreht und
in Deutschland verschärft sich die Krise
die Energiepreise explodieren die
Industrieproduktion stoppt
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck musste
heute eine dystrip Prognose präsentieren
schlechter als noch im Frühjahr erwartet
wir prognostizieren jetzt im Herbst ein
Wachstum noch ein Wachstum von 1,4
Prozent aber im April diesen Jahres
haben wir noch 2,2 Prozent vorhergesagt
für das nächste Jahr sind wir dann mit
minus 0,4 Prozent also einem negativen
Wachstum in einer Rezession trübe
Aussichten denn das bedeutet im Klartext
weniger Wohlstand für alle die Kaufkraft
der privaten Haushalte wird im nächsten
Jahr schrumpfen das heißt es müssen die
Konsumenten insgesamt den Gürtel etwas
enger schnallen ein weiteres Problem die
weltweiten Lieferketten sind aus dem
Takt geraten wichtige Rohstoffe aus
Übersee kommen mit Verspätung oder gar
nicht mehr an und wenn sind sie teurer
als zuvor vor allem das und die
Energiepreise führen zu einer Inflation
wie es in der Bundesrepublik noch nicht
gab 8% in diesem Jahr
eine Geldentwertung die Geringverdiener
besonders stark trifft der Staat müsse
daher noch mehr tun meinen
Gewerkschafter es geht natürlich auch
Perspektive darum Arbeitsplätze zu
sichern und Kaufkraft zu stabilisieren
und deswegen werden wir auch in den
nächsten Tarifrunden dafür kämpfen dass
wir eine real- und Stabilisierung
erfahren aber ohne zusätzliche
politische Maßnahmen wird uns das nicht
gelingen ob der Staat die Krise abfangen
kann hängt auch davon ab wie sich die
Energiepreise entwickeln steigen sie
weiter wie bisher sind die heutigen
Prognosen womöglich schon bald überholt
nach massivem Raketenbeschuss durch das
russische Militär auf ukrainische Städte
bedankte sich Ukrainisch Präsident jetzt
im ZDF-Interview für ein von Deutschland
geliefertes hoch modernes
Flugabwehrsystem außerdem betonte er es
nütze nichts vor Putin zurückzuweichen
der Westen müsse Russland mit aller
Härte entgegentreten mehr von Alicia
jung
unter Trümmern begraben diese Familie in
saporisha hat wie durch ein Wunder
überlebt getroffen von einer russischen
Rakete Dienstag Nacht seit Montag
attackiert Russland die Ukraine in allen
Teilen des Landes es gibt Tote und
Verletzte auch viele Zivilisten im
Interview mit dem ZDF macht Präsident
selenski noch einmal ganz deutlich es
kann keine Möglichkeiten mehr für
Verhandlungen mit Putin geben
er ist für unser Land ein Terrorist mit
dem niemand über irgendetwas verhandeln
will deswegen sagen wir weil wir als
Land für Frieden stehen ja wir werden
mit Russland reden natürlich aber nur
mit einer anderen Person
um Raketen abfangen zu können fordert
die Ukraine vor allem Unterstützung für
die Luftverteidigung das deutsche Iris
tslm System ist inzwischen eingetroffen
im Süden wie diesen Ort bei hässon
erobern die Ukrainer immer mehr Gebiete
zurück
die Mittel- und Truppen der russischen
und der ukrainischen Armee sind nicht
vergleichbar aber wir haben die
Initiative ergriffen und wir machen
Fortschritte deshalb beschießen Sie uns
mit Raketen weil sie auf dem
Schlachtfeld nichts ausrichten können
sie wollen uns Angst machen und uns
brechen
er fordert eine klare geschlossene
Haltung gegenüber Russland von Europa
lebt noch mit dem Gefühl der Angst was
wird Russland tun wie wird Putin
Antworten und was wird passieren wenn
Putin nicht mehr da ist
die Welt entscheide jetzt darüber wie
wir in Zukunft leben werden sagt er
unserer Reporterin zum Schluss
der ukrainische Präsident selenski im
ZDF exklusiv Interview alles dazu finden
Sie auch in der ZDF heute App ja und
auch die Nato hat bei ihrem Treffen
heute klargestellt die Ukraine soll noch
mehr militärische Unterstützung bekommen
die Rüstungsindustrie müsste mehr und
müssen schneller produzieren die Devise
laute nicht einschüchtern lassen auch
nicht von den nuklearen Drohungen Putins
aus Brüssel berichtet Gunnar Krüger
es heißt Iris t SLM und soll helfen
gegen das was die Ukraine russischen
Terror nennt Luftabwehr in einem Radius
von 40 Kilometern gegen Drohnen und
Raketen verspricht der deutsche
Hersteller bezahlt die deutsche
Bundesregierung das ist nur der Anfang
und wir brauchen mehr schreibt der
Verteidigungsminister der Ukraine mit
Dank an die Kollegin aus Deutschland die
verkündet den Brüssel heute die erste
Lieferung nicht ohne Stolz aber mit
Verzögerung zu dem folgen erst 2023 drei
weitere Systeme
das sind hochkomplexe hochmoderne
Systeme und die brauchen eine gewisse
Zeit aber wir tun alles damit es so
schnell wie möglich geschickt es ist der
Nato-Generalsekretär der druckmacht auf
alle Mitglieder angesichts von Russlands
Angriffswelle
das zeigt alles den dringenden Bedarf
für Luftverteidigung die Verbündeten
haben geliefert aber wir brauchen noch
mehr
Event more es ist nicht die NATO sondern
die sogenannte Rammstein Gruppe aus als
50 Staaten die liefert Vorsitz haben die
USA die auch zwei Systeme versprechen
und weitere auch erst noch produzieren
wir bringen unsere Waffenindustrie nun
zusammen damit Sie dieses Thema
produzieren die die Ukraine braucht ohne
Abstriche an unserer eigenen Sicherheit
winterfest will der Westen die Ukraine
machen klar ist dafür reicht kein Griff
ins Lager dafür braucht es
Kriegsproduktion
wegen der Explosion auf der krimbrücke
hat Russland 8 Personen festgenommen
fünf sein Russen drei kämmen aus der
Ukraine und Armenien so Moskau aus
Geheimdienst FSB organisiert worden sei
der Anschlag vom ukrainischen
Geheimdienst Kiew bestreitetes am
Samstag hatte eine Detonation die Brücke
schwer beschädigt vier Menschen kamen
nach offiziellen Angaben ums Leben die
Brücke verbindet Russland und die 2014
von Moskau annektierte Halbinsel Krim
Polen meldet heute ein Leck an der
Pipeline durch Bar das ist die
Hauptleitung über die Rohöl nach
Deutschland fließt an einem Abschnitt im
Zentrum von Polen trat-öl aus
Ministerpräsident moravitzki sagte es
sei noch unklar ob es sich um Sabotage
oder einen Unfall handelt trotz des Lex
erhielten deutsche Raffinerien weiter Öl
sagt die Bundesregierung die
Versorgungssicherheit sei gewährleistet
die EU hat sich nach Angaben von
Diplomaten auf weitere Sanktionen gegen
Iran geeinigt die am Montag auf den Weg
gebracht werden sollen Hintergrund das
brutale Vorgehen des Regimes gegen die
Protestbewegung nach dem Tod der
22-jährigen Massa Amini vor vier Wochen
und in vielen Städten da dauern die
Unruhen und Proteste an die Bürger
fordern immer deutlicher ein Ende des
Regimes rückwahlport berichtet die Woche
begann mit Studenten in Teheran die Tod
dem Diktator riefen dann gingen erstmals
Arbeiter in den Raffinerien und
Ölanlagen am Persischen Golf in den
Streik und forderten Weg mit dem Regime
heute demonstrierten Rechtsanwälte vor
der Anwaltskammer in Teheran und gleich
neben dem Präsidentenpalast forderten
Schülerinnen Frauen Leben Freiheit
Irans oberster Führer zeigte sich
unterdessen abgeschottet im Palast
unbeeindruckt alles Teil einer
ausländischen Verschwörung man setzt
weiter auf gewaltsame Niederschlagung
diese vereinzelten Proteste sind spontan
die werden gezielt durch Provokationen
aus dem Ausland angeheizt und gesteuert
in Sananda einer mehrheitlich von Kurden
bewohnten Stadt in Westiran kommt es
seit Tagen zu schweren blutigen
Auseinandersetzungen Sicherheitskräfte
setzen dabei auch Schusswaffen ein
Menschenrechtsorganisationen sprechen
inzwischen von landesweit mindestens 210
Toten Präsident raisi lud heute zu einer
internationalen Islamkonferenz ein in
der er die großartigen Errungenschaften
islamischer Zivilisation pries
wir haben einen passenden Lebensstil für
die Menschen von heute
diese Iranerinnen sehen das ganz anders
auch mit hub-konzerten protestieren
viele Autofahrerinnen immer wieder gegen
das Regime die Staatsmacht reagiert mit
brutaler Härte
zurück nach Deutschland beim Wohnungsbau
das scheint ein ehrgeiziges Ziel der
Regierungskoalition zu wackeln
eigentlich wollte die Bundesregierung
bis Ende des Jahres 400.000 neue
Wohnungen bauen lassen die dringend
gebraucht werden aber es gibt erhebliche
Zweifel ob das noch klappt was jetzt in
einem schwierigen Umfeld für ausreichend
Wohnraum zu tun wäre darüber haben heute
Experten und Regierung geredet Winnie
Hischer dazu
eine Baulücke mitten in Dresden hier
sollten Sozialwohnungen entstehen aber
die Stadt hatte nicht genug Geld
einige Kilometer weiter wird noch fertig
gebaut mehr aber auch nicht hunderte von
Sozialwohnungen gestrichen
2200 Euro pro Quadratmeter damit waren
die Budgets der Förderprogramme bei
Planung ausgestattet Zahlen aus besseren
Zeiten
wenn ich heute neu baden würde bin ich
bei fünfeinhalb bis 6000 Euro den
Quadratmeter steigende Kosten
Belastungen durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine lieferkettenprobleme die
Bundesregierung will trotzdem ihr altes
Ziel nicht aufgeben 400.000 neue
Wohnungen pro Jahr wir halten an dem
Ziel fest das muss ausdrücklich gesagt
werden wir wollen diese Zielsetzung
verfolgen und die Wohnungsbau Zahlen auf
diese Größenordnung steigern gerade auch
wenn jetzt die Zeiten viel schwieriger
werden um das Ziel zu erreichen ist es
richtig dass wir das tun mehr Wohnraum
soll geschaffen werden durch mehr
Digitalisierung bei
Genehmigungsverfahren Baukosten sollen
begrenzt werden durch zum Beispiel
serielles bauen schon im Frühjahr waren
14,5 Milliarden Euro für sozialen
Wohnungsbau zugesagt worden
14,5 Milliarden sind wirklich viel Geld
das ist gar keine Frage aber die
Sozialwohnungen müssen in Zukunft auch
von privaten wieder gebaut werden und
dazu muss es einen finanziellen Anreiz
geben der ausreicht und private
Investoren davon zu überzeugen dass sie
Sozialwohnungen bauen und der reicht
nicht für 100.000 Wohnungen auch nicht
mit 14,5 Milliarden auch 400.000 neue
Wohnungen pro Jahr sein unrealistisch
sagen Experten der Immobilien und
Baubranche die heute mit am Tisch saßen
Olaf Scholz weiß dass er dieses Ziel
dieses Jahr nicht erreicht er will sich
daran messen lassen er wird daran
gemessen werden
unterwegs in Deutschland ohne großen
Tross Bundespräsident Steinmeier nennt
diese mehrtägigen Besucher Ortszeit
diesmal ist der in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und zwar in
Neustrelitz im Gespräch mit Menschen auf
dem Wochenmarkt Themen auch hier in der
strukturschwachen Region die Sorge der
Menschen vor der aktuellen Energiekrise
Steinmeier führt noch bis morgen seine
Amtsgeschäfte in einem Hotel der Stadt
so jetzt wird es außerirdisch die NASA
meldet einen historischen Erfolg im All
erstmals ist es gelungen mit einer
gezielten Kollision einen Himmelskörper
auf eine andere Bahn zu lenken vor zwei
Wochen hatte die Nase eine Sonde in
einen
Asteroiden stürzen lassen Messergebnisse
haben das jetzt bestätigt der
Himmelskörper änderte tatsächlich
deutlich seinen Kurs eine wichtige
Erkenntnis um die Erde vorherannahenden
Objekten zu schützen der Asteroid
allerdings stellte keine Gefahr da
so wir sind jetzt ganz flott bei der
Champions League Christine fröhliche
zuerst RB Leipzig kommt auf europäischer
Bühne immer besser in Schwung und hat es
weiter selbst in der Hand ins
Achtelfinale einzuziehen Erleichterungen
und großer Jubel nach dem 2:0 beim
schottischen Meister zeltic glasgasco
so fühlt sich ein Auswärtssieg in der
Champions League an Wille und Effizienz
waren nötig gegen gefährlich auf
Spielende Schotten und ein Timo Werner
in Spiellaune per Kopf sein Treffer zum
1:0 in der 75 Minute nach Vorarbeit von
Silva das 2:0 bereitete Werner vor Emil
Forsberg vollendete hin- und Rückspiel
gegen Celtic konnte RB für sich
entscheiden das war sehr wichtig für uns
und jetzt ist Donalds eine Art Endspiel
wir haben es eine eigenen Hand wir sind
zwei der Moment und ja leichter geht es
ja nicht alles wieder zurecht gerückt
das Team von Trainer Marco Rose kann auf
das Weiterkommen ins Achtelfinale hoffen
ebenso Borussia Dortmund wobei der BVB
seine Chance verpasst hat vorzeitig die
Ko-Runde zu sichern vor heimischer
Kulisse reichte es nur zu einem eins zu
eins Jude Bellingham erzielte den
Ausgleich in der 35 Minute als
Tabellenzweiter ist die Ausgangsposition
für dort und vor den restlichen zwei
Gruppenspielen aber weiterhin sehr gut
und alle Highlights Analysen und stimmen
zum vierten Spieltag von 23 Uhr an den
ZDF-Sportstudio live UEFA Champions
League sowie online in der ZDF heute App
darin auch ausführlich zu den heutigen
Partien der Bayern Leverkusen und
Frankfurt ja die Eintracht will nach dem
Bundesliga Debakel in Bochum zurück zu
alter Stärke und an den Punktgewinn 0:0
im Hinspiel nun auswärts bei Tottenham
Hotspur anknüpfen
Oliver Glasner hat in der Bundesliga
zuletzt ein paar Stammspieler geschont
dann gab sein 03 beim tabellennetzen in
Bochum doch den Kopf wollen die
Frankfurter deshalb nicht verlieren was
sollen wir sagen bleiben wir zu Hause
weil wir in Bochum verloren haben und
verlieren hier geben das Spiel kampflos
ab das ist ja nicht unsere Einstellung
und sondern unsere Einstellung ist ins
Spiel zu gehen unsere beste Leistung zu
zeigen ja dann trauen wir uns auch zu
hier zu gewinnen mit den Stammspielern
hätte aus dem Remy im Hinspiel gegen
Tottenham auch ein Sieg werden können
mindestens noch so ein Unentschieden am
Abend in London und die Ko-Phase bleibt
in Reichweite
schaue ich mir an danke Christin wir
haben jetzt noch die Zahlen vom
Mittwochslotto die lauten 16 21 26 35 48
49 Superzahl 2 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
lotto.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Textseite
ja das heißt erstmal Abschied nehmen vom
goldenen Oktober von Nordwesten wird es
wolkiger wechselhafter windiger und
Regen fällt auch mehr dazu gleich mit
Katja horneffer ich empfehle Ihnen noch
das heute journal mit Christian Sievers
um 21 Uhr und wir sehen uns dann morgen
wieder schönen Abend für Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt heißt es erstmal
wenigstens vorübergehend Abschied nehmen
vom goldenen Oktoberwetter denn von
Nordwesten wird es wolkiger windiger
wechselhafter und etwas Regen fällt auch
heute gab es ja noch mal vielen Nebel
und jetzt eine Nacht bereitet der sich
hier in Süddeutschland wieder aus von
Nordwesten kommen die dichteren Wolken
schon heran zwischen Berlin-Brandenburg
und dem Erzgebirge aber ist es zum Teil
klar und dann wird es dort auch am
kältesten dann sinken die Werte bis drei
Grad und das droht Bodenfrost sonst
bleibt die Nacht bei 9 bis 4 Grad milder
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen bei
13 Grad in den westlichen Mittelgebirgen
auch an der Ostsee bis zu 19 Grad gibt
es dagegen Invest Sachsen im Osten gibt
es morgen Vormittag noch eine Chance auf
Sonne im Süden dagegen halten sich die
Nebelfelder C und von Nordwesten kommt
dann dieser Regen heran das ist gar
nicht so sehr viel Regen aber er weitet
sich im Laufe des Nachmittags ostwärts
aus am längsten trocken bis zum Abend
bleibt es wohl hier in
Berlin-Brandenburg im östlichen Sachsen
und auch in Niederbayern in den nächsten
Tagen wird es sehr wechselhaft unserem
freundlichen wird es dann noch im
Nordosten sein am Alpenrand kann es auch
mal länger regnen der Sonntag bringt uns
schon wieder mehr Sonne für uns alle bei
Temperaturen bis 23 Grad guten Abend